matt is with us in springfield missouri
hey matt welcome to the show how can we
help
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
um so um long story short here
my wife and i bought a house in 2012
at about 160 000 and we spent the last
eight years
paying off our house and we just did
that last year in july
and now my wife's wanting to move again
and because her office got closed down
during the covid pandemic
and she ended up working remotely from
home now permanently
and so i'm having trouble coming to
terms with wanting to possibly take on
another mortgage
and so i'm kind of needing some advice
on how i should handle this
uh um okay so your current home is worth
what
we bought the home for 160 in 2012 and
right now it's probably worth about 280.
okay and what's wrong with the house you
have now
uh nothing wrong with it she just one
she doesn't like the layout and two
there's no office space for her we're in
a home like she works from the kitchen
table
and we have you know kids and everything
and uh it
gets noisy if you can't you know do
client calls and stuff like that because
it's
too distracting okay so why couldn't you
buy a 280 000
home with a different layout and that
had an office
we've been looking and we haven't found
anything
in our area uh of that price and uh with
the layout
because you haven't looked in that
neighborhood you've been looking in
those expensive neighborhoods
you could say that yeah no i'm sure of
it i mean
you know yeah that's the logo you're
looking in the wrong neighborhood if you
want to stay out of debt right
well i i do want to stay out of that i
don't well why are you looking in a
neighborhood that has debt
uh that's a good question but uh the the
area has just shot up so high that
you know well then yours should have
been shot up
i mean a 280 000 home in springfield
missouri is no slouch dude
that's a that's a decent house and you
could have a differently configured home
that included a different layout and
config
included that for that same money and
just swap houses
yeah but what we're doing is we're using
all this other bs as an excuse to move
up in house that's really what it comes
down to
yeah yeah i guess you can say that yeah
i mean i want a different kitchen that's
got like 70 000 more worth of crap in it
and i'm using this i'm working at the
kitchen table whining as my excuse to go
into that again
so where in the process did you all lose
or did she lose the vision
of being debt-free on your home is uh
worth it
uh well i think it's just been over the
course of since she's had to work from
home
uh the constant interruptions with uh
kids being in the area and her trying to
handle phone calls and get work done
and um go renter in office
yeah we've we've talked about that um
but we we do pay for a private school as
well
for our children and um
we haven't been able to justify the cost
of getting a rental office or
her her business did have her set up to
go to a rental office's office spaces
and then they got rid of that option
what kind of work is she doing
she's a hr consultant so she's on the
phone
80 of the day yeah she's handling she
does a
compensation mail analysis uh executive
analysis
who's watching the kids when they're not
in school like how many kids are running
around
we have two kids and it'll usually be me
watching them um but i i do shift work
so i'll
one week i'm working nights the next
week i'm working evenings
so i have a crazy work schedule i work
weekends yeah well
let me just tell you something by
yourself let me tell you dave's
absolutely right you too
this is a relationship thing you guys
got to sit down and and re
re-establish the why why did we do all
this for eight years
what was the whole purpose of this and
you know this is a pretty easy
solve number one you're living in a 160
dollar area so today's point the two
days
yeah i know well i'm saying that's what
they were yeah that's what they bought
at yeah and then so there's a couple
neighborhoods up so i think it's unsafe
it's not like schools are awful so i
think this big bad world you're in
the other thing is is that you know she
can work at the coffee shop or something
just you know
and make phone calls and step out or do
whatever i just i just think this idea
that we got to move somewhere
uh for her to have a place to work
besides the kitchen table
i i just think that's a relationship
thing where you guys have to
re-establish the why behind this
and then say okay we're willing to do
this but we're not willing to
go beyond the 280. and if we can't get
happy with something for 280 cash
then you have to come up with another
solve until you save up enough
to be able to do something you want i
mean what's your household income
175 a year go rent an office
yeah okay today
okay and then if you want to trade
houses trade houses but that off
listen the tail's wagging the dog here
you're making a bad financial decision
for a temporary situation
right yeah we're working at the kitchen
table is not the way it's going to be
for the next decade
right she's not gonna be at the kitchen
table for a decade and you don't you
don't go
buy a house uh because of something that
happened with covid
uh these are you know i i do not know
when she'll be back at work or when
they'll be funding the office but you
make
plenty of money and so for you know what
four or five hundred bucks you can go
rent a single office in one of these
office suites
and just you know she can plan herself
down there and then she's got a work
environment that's reasonable
and then if you want to trade houses for
a better layout that's fine
you could guys can do whatever you want
you got a lot of excuses for a guy that
called in wanting help not to do this
and i'm just telling you don't do it
there's no chance
no chance that i'm going into that in
this situation
none this is all a bunch of i want it
and i'm a little bit uncomfortable and
i'm sorry you're uncomfortable
i'm sorry she's uncomfortable whoopi
don't put yourself back into a mortgage
over that
you finally got yourself free man
remember what it was like having that
thing hanging around your neck
don't go back into the noose don't stick
your head back in there man
don't put your foot in a bear trap again
them things hurt man don't do it
don't do it please please don't do it
and
and you know but you you you know is
there a valid
part of this that she's trying to do
business in an
unprofessional situation yeah go around
an office and do it tomorrow
that's what i would do in your situation
i'm not going into debt
for an office in your home over covet
no you know what the new thing is now is
literally these uh
closets that are offices it's like a new
thing
uh you look it up online i'm not kidding
you where people are turning closets
into miniature offices
we could at least do that no i'm not
going in the closet
[Laughter]
she makes 175 000. i agree i'm trying to
give him a non-rent option i just you
know there's another place besides the
kitchen table yeah but i agree with you
you could go get an office
yeah yeah but here's the thing it's a
vis where there is no vision the people
perish
if you work really hard to get out of
debt because you believe
that your life is so much better being
debt-free you have so much higher
probability of building wealth by being
debt-free
you would never go back but you quit
believing that somewhere along the line
and we're willing to trade that for the
inconvenience of the current situation
and i'm not willing to trade it no the
the difference is that
when we went broke and lost everything i
said never again and i meant it
never again are these bozos gonna have
their thumb on my neck
never again is american express gonna
call my house unless it's a wrong
number never again
there's not a chance i am not going back
there's not anything you people can do
to scare me enough
there's nothing you can do to make me
mad enough there's not anything you can
do to make me greedy
enough or passionate enough to go into
debt
the borrower is slave to the lender and
i am
free and i am never
going back it's easy for me to say and i
can't imagine you and stacey having that
conversation to be any different
no yeah it's look
every time that you allow your emotions
to drive you
then then you lose sight of decisions
that you have made
you know what i mean and your critical
thinking skills critical thinking is
gone
and i feel this i feel this i feel this
and in this situation you made a great
recommendation
they can upgrade and still be
mortgage-free